But I wanna show you a different approach,...
...and this is this robot over here,..
...which has four legs. It has eight motors, four on the knees and four on the hip.
It has also two tilt sensors that tell the machine how it... which way it's tilting.
But this machine doesn't know what it looks like.
You look at it and you see it has four legs,..
...the machine doesn't know if it's a snake, if it's a tree,...
...it doesn't have any idea what it looks like,...
...but it's gonna try to find that out.
So initially, it does some random motion...
...and it then... it tries to figure out what it might look like,...
...and you're seeing a lot of things passing through its mind.
There's a lot of self-models...
...that try to explain the relationship between actuation and sensing,...
...and then, tries to do a second action...
...that creates the most disagreement among predictions of these alternative models,...
...like a scientist in a lab.
Then it does that and tries to explain that, and prune out its self-models.
This is already the last cycle...
...and you can see it's pretty much figured out what itself looks like,...
...and once it has a self-model, it can use that to derive a pattern of locomotion.
So, what you're seeing here are a couple of machines... a pattern of locomotion.
We were hoping that it's gonna have a kind of evil, spidery walk...
...but instead, it created this pretty lame way of moving forward.
But when you look at that,...
...you have to remember that this machine did not do any physical trials on how to move forward...
...nor did it have a model of itself.
It kinda figured out what it looks like...
...and how to move forward,...
...and then, actually tried that out.